hi my name is Jim Moore and I'm gonna
show you how to iron your dress shirt in
90 seconds so you all know what an
ironing board looks like this is an
ironing board but I think what you don't
know is that it's really this end of the
ironing board that you should be ironing
on so the first thing you do is you turn
it around these are the two tools that
you need a nice hot iron
get yourself a little water bottle like
this empty out the water no water in an
iron I'm gonna ask you to turn it to its
highest setting so you're gonna be
spraying the bottom of the iron making
sure you hear that nice sizzle the 90
second iron is front collar and cuffs
that's all you need if you're gonna be
wearing a jacket
so let's position the shirt right onto
that flat end of the ironing board you
can see it just lays in there perfectly
we want to soak it down pretty well with
our sprayer and just like go at it like
crazy and I'm a big puller
get really aggressive with the shirt
that's one side done and then I'm gonna
do the same thing for the other side
when you get to the button placket soak
the placket hold on to it with your left
hand and just pull it as you're ironing
this is gonna be this little area of the
shoulder which is gonna need a little
bit of touch up so angle it a little bit
hit that right there
I recommend ironing the shirt collar on
the underside again you can never get it
too wet really massive - how it hold it
over on the seam this is gonna make your
collar sit better it's also going to
accommodate your your necktie very well
okay the collar is done go to your cups
the inside of the cuffs is what you want
to do not the outside soak it a little
bit flatten that out put it on a hanger
there's your 90 seconds button the top
button to your shirt you can see it's
gonna sit nice and flat and none of
those wrinkles are going to come back
into play
I'm Jim Moore and that's how to iron a
dress shirt in 90 seconds